the suspect in the kidnapping and
killing of a memphis kindergarten
teacher is due to return to court today
to face more charges including first
degree murder
memphis police say that they found eliza
fletcher's body four days after she was
abducted during an early morning jog
some critics say the suspect a convicted
kidnapper should have still been in
prison there are a lot of questions here
elise preston has the latest on this
investigation
police discovered the body of eliza
fletcher monday in a grassy lot behind a
vacant duplex roughly seven miles from
where the kindergarten teacher and
mother of two was last seen
according to an affidavit tire tracks
and an odor of decay led officers to the
gruesome discovery also recovered a
trash bag containing purple shorts like
the ones fletcher was last seen wearing
while the outcome
of this investigation is not what we
hoped for
we are nonetheless pleased to remove
this dangerous predator off the streets
of memphis you're charged with
especially aggravated kidnapping
investigators say 38-year-old cleo the
apston violently forced fletcher into
his suv while she was out jogging at
about 4 a.m last friday fletcher's cell
phone was found nearby along with a pair
of sandals that had traces of the
suspect's dna abstinent previously
kidnapped a prominent memphis attorney
when he was 16 years old abston served
nearly 20 years in prison for that crime
but had been sentenced to 24. charlie
caswell is a shelby county commissioner
you have fought against recidivism here
in memphis for for a very long time did
the system fail in in this situation i
don't know all the details on it but it
looked that way very much so but shelby
county district attorney steve mulroy
noted abstinence served 85 percent of
his sentence i think it's easy to take
one particular case and
try to extrapolate from that i think
what we just need to do right now is
just focus on going forward and making
sure that justice is done in this
particular case
now the district attorney tells us he
has no reason to believe fletcher was
targeted calling this an isolated attack
by a stranger abstinent has yet to enter
a plea in a statement fletcher's family
called her a joy to so many saying they
are heartbroken and devastated by this
senseless loss tony
senseless is the word for it elise thank
you very much i mean it is a bottomless
tragedy we didn't know this woman and i
feel heartbroken because it's so random
that apparently she jogged all the time
and that he didn't know her she didn't
know him and to hear the details about
somebody that clearly should not have
been out on the streets just makes you
angry in addition to all the sadness
he's behind a family two little ones yes
and a husband it's awful